CHRIS.
>> Chris: JENNIFER GRIFFIN AT
THE PENTAGON.
THANKS.
LET'S TALK MORE NOW ABOUT
PROSPECTS FOR MILITARY ACTION
AGAINST SYRIA.
TEXAS REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN MAC
THORNBERRY IS CHAIR OF THE HOUSE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAN
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMA,
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAI
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAW
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAN
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMA
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAO
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAP
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAC
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAK
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAU
REGISTERED          MR. CHAIRMAP
ON THE COMMENT FROM DEFENSE
SECRETARY MATTIS THAT HE WANTS
TO SEE INTERNATIONAL CHEMICAL
WEAPONS INSPECTORS IN SYRIA THIS
WEEKEND.
DOES IT INDICATE TO YOU THERE
WILL BE NO U.S. STRIKE UNTIL
THOSE INSPECTORS ARE SAFELY OUT
OF SYRIA?
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE NOT SAY WHEN OR HOW OR WHERE
WE MAY ACT.
CLEARLY, IF ASSAD ALLOWS THESE
CHEMICAL INSPECTORS AND, WE WILL
BE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT COULD ENDANGER THEM.
AT THE SAME TIME, I DON'T THINK
MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE THERE'S A
HIGH LIKELIHOOD HE'S GOING TO
LET ACTUAL INSPECTORS IN TO
PROVE WHAT HE HAS DONE.
WHICH IS A TERRIBLE ATROCITY.
WE CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF THAT.